soy otro loco de esos que creen que la
vida siempre juega a nuestro favor soy
otro loco de los que creen que todo lo
que nos pasa absolutamente todo lo que
nos pasa sin ninguna excepción bueno
malo más malo más bueno siempre es para
nuestro favor
y así me gusta vivir y así ha logrado
vivir muchos años y me encanta vivir así
pero se puso a prueba de esta creencia
cuando la delincuencia tocó a mi casa
cuando la delincuencia tocó a los seres
que más quiero ya le dije qué hago
sabía que lo tradicional de ir a
levantar un acta lo que nos dicen que
hagamos ratificarla darle seguimiento no
era suficiente porque yo lo quería que
ganaran los ladrones porque por cómo fue
parecían amateurs y los iban a meter a
la universidad del crimen terminó ya
aceptado por toda la sociedad para que
los meten para que salgan graduados y
luego me hagan algo peor lo que hago qué
hago si el universo me está mandando
esto para qué es
entonces hice lo que podía hacer lo
bueno de vivir una ciudad como más
hablar una ciudad pequeña que todo mundo
conoce a alguien que conoce a alguien
que conoce allí y con eso llega el
director del penal de la de mazatlán le
dice quiero trabajar dentro no te puedo
pagar no te voy a cobrar sirve que yo
pongo en práctica lo que aprendo en
todas las cosas que estaba aprendiendo
de coaching y demás
bienvenido me presta un lugar y empecé a
trabajar dentro del penal iba una vez a
la semana trabajaba un par de horas con
los hombres y un par de horas con las
mujeres les puedo contar cientos de
historias allá dentro maravillosas pero
él solo les vengo a contar una una nada
más
pero no la van a disfrutar
si no hacemos esto
necesitan apagar su máquina de juicio en
segundos lo que les voy a platicar por
favor no juzguen si está bien o mal no
juzguen si es correcto o incorrecto es
nada más apaguen un platito su máquina
de juicio y traten de disfrutar esta
historia
todas la semanas iba trabajaba con las
mujeres llegaban en grupitos la vida
dentro es muy similar que afuera hay
mucho estrés pero había una mujer la voy
a llamar soledad ok para términos de
esta plática iba siempre llegaba a solas
no platicaba con nadie las miradas de
todos ya las conocía y había bondad en
sus miradas en ella no en ella su mirada
me daba miedo la verdad no me pasaba con
los hombres solo me pasaba con ella
y siempre buscaba que participara
soledad algo que tienes participar
era la primera en llegar y la última en
irse nunca faltaba siguiente semana iba
y no participaba
un día no fue me llamó la atención un
acuerdo que yo tenía con todos ahí es
que jamás les iba a preguntar qué delito
cometieron no quería juicios de mi parte
no quería un prejuicio pero cuando me
dicen le digo por qué no vino soledad y
contenido así tener en el juzgado y tuvo
que ir dice mauricio y dicen ellas ya no
tengo pláticas con ella no la no busque
su participación porque aquí está si es
mala
guau estoy hablando del lugar donde
están los más malos
dentro de los más malos y es la más mala
de todos los malos
perdón pero un automático me salió pues
que hizo dice chin ya lo dije
y me contesta uno mató a su hijita de
cinco años
y me lo dicen cuando mi hijita tenía
se me erizó la piel
a como detalle siguiente semana fue
soledad y la verdad ahora me da más
miedo
ahora sintió modos pero viajaba y
quieres participar pero quieres
participar
un día
fuimos caminando llegamos a un tema que
tratábamos que amaba la culpa se queda
al final del taller y me dice señor no
visión para platicar con usted adelante
quiero sentir culpa
y yo estaba hablando que la culpa no es
buena y ella quería sentir culpa puse
cara de que ya sabía qué delito había
cometido y ella lo notó dijo ya sabes lo
que hice verdad lo sé
soy mala verdad
para contestarle que sí
pero le dije no
qué podemos hacer le dije mira ya no
tenemos tiempo pero la siguiente semana
me queda un ratito a trabajar contigo y
pide a la enfermería y platicamos ok yo
creo ir salí a hablar con mis coaches
con mis terapeutas qué hago yo
queriéndolo endosar el problema venga
conmigo no hay ayuda en vez no es tuyo y
si te llego a ti es para ti listo llega
la siguiente semana con más seguridad y
empecé a trabajar con ella ya tenía
totalmente bloqueado el evento de la
muerte de su hija estaba muy drogada
tenía totalmente bloqueada todo lo que
fue su infancia no la quería recordar y
poco a poco fuimos armando un
rompecabezas
lo primero que necesita hacer fue que
confiar en mí porque no confiaba en los
hombres no confiaba en que un hombre se
le acercara si no tiene un objetivo
sexual ahorita van a entender por qué no
confiaba en que un hombre se le acercara
sin un objetivo de abuso lo noté es lo
primero que necesite trabajar
seguimos trabajando y ella empezó a
recordar
escuchen lo que pasó a los cinco años su
mamá
nunca conocí a su papá su mamá iba a
trabajar a la ciudad de más atrás sobre
un pequeño poblado a una hora además
aclaró la mamá iba a trabajar todos los
días de niña pero era muy lejos se
empezó a quedarse en mazatlán consiguió
lugar para vivir y dejó a la niña
encargada con su pareja por el padrastro
un día el padrastro
la persona toca
con eso
un día abusó de ella
otro día y otro día 56 años
el padrastro le empezó a comprar ropita
y todos desean alrededor ay qué lindo
papá tienes y la tenía amenazada si
dices algo mató a tu mamá
suelo amor a su madre como herramienta
de abuso
no conforme con eso
el señor quería conseguir recursos y la
empezó a rentar
para que los demás amigos compañeros
fueron abusar de ella y le pagar
hagan esos fue de sus cinco años a sus
12 años no saquen calculadora yo ya lo
hice son cientos miles de veces que
abusaron de ella
esta es la mala que me vaya adentro
quién de ustedes quiere ser el juez de
ella
durante la mano y quien se atreve a
juzgarla como la más mala entre las
malas
no hace su hija queda embarazada no sabe
de quién nace su hija y ella la amaba
quería darle lo mejor de ella quería
totalmente sabe salvarla la niña
pero los hábitos su historia la marca
havana
un día
fiesta hombres drogas
y los hombres empiezan a acercar a su
hijita
la empiezan a manosear
y presidio
apretar su cuello hasta que dejara de
respirar
la quería matar
o quería parar la repetición
cada quien decida lo
mejor es que más tengo más tiempo porque
si tuviera que acabar aquí obviamente es
una historia de tragedia
pero la historia no le damos una
historia de tragedia
nuestra soledad es una historia de amor
es una historia de paz de libertad
cuando entendió eso ella sintió culpa
sintió mucha culpa
lloro
y pataleó y volvió a llorar y me decía
qué chingados me hiciste donde el inglés
pero así de dablan hecho
si ya me dejaste peor cómo voy a vivir
así
efe te dejaba libros audios todo lo que
pudiera y lo devoraba y lo demoraba
meditaba rezaba sea todo lo que pudiera
ella yo
después de la culpa vino el perdón a sí
misma a su padrastro ya todos los
hombres
y después de eso vino la liberación
hoy señoras señoritas es un ser libre
es una inspiración y es un ejemplo para
muchas personas de vivir en libertad
allá adentro porque todavía faltan
algunos años conozco gente que vive aquí
afuera mucho más presa que ella
conozco gente allá dentro que vive con
mucha más libertad que muchos que
estamos aquí
ella es un amor de mujer yo me enamoré
de ella y no hablo de la mujer habló de
su transformación habló de su proceso
habló de la capacidad de resiliencia que
tenemos los seres humanos habló de la
energía que tiene el amor que transmite
es tan grande el amor que hoy el penal
donde ella habita su nido de amor ella
entendió que el día más obscuro para
todas las los reos que llegan ahí
hombres y mujeres es el primer día sobre
todo los que piensan por primera vez
allí ella adopta todos los que van
llegando ella sigue lo que empezamos ahí
y ya lo sigue dando día tras día trabaja
con ellas y lo único que hace es
repartir amor ahí adentro la más mala
entre todos los mal
que seríamos capaces de hacer tú y yo
si no viviéramos en una prisión
la verdadera prisión de ella estaba aquí
la prisión de ella no empezó el día que
tocó la cárcel la prisión de ella empezó
cuando todos nosotros la sociedad nos
olvidamos de ellos hoy estás escuchando
a los que nadie escucha a los que no
queremos escuchar a los más malos entre
los malos y solo es una historia la que
más me marcó a mí pero hay cientos hay
miles ahí y que vamos a hacer seguir
refugiándonos en nuestra casa seguir
combatiéndolos ellos son nosotros
nosotros somos ellos si dejamos de
atender sus necesidades tarde o temprano
van a llegar a tu casa ya la mía otra
vez yo no quiero eso yo quiero que
lleguen el día que tengan amor para dar
lo que tengan más oscuridad que sembrar
está en tus manos y está en la mía está
la mano de las autoridades a las
responsables
el miedo es la única prisión el miedo es
nuestra única prisión
y el miedo es la prisión de la que
podemos salir todos y cuando salimos de
ella el amor nos hace libres y entonces
podemos practicar esto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]